in this video i'm going to show you my
process for turning a photograph into a
title shot
in after effects
[Music]
hey everyone this is cameron with motion
science and in today's video i'm going
to show you my process for creating
beautiful title shots in after effects
using only a photograph this is a really
simple technique to pull off so let's
dive in and get started so let me show
you very quickly what we're going to
create
in this lesson today i'm calling this
into the darkness
and it's a very moody atmospheric
title piece that's actually very simple
to create and i want to show you how i
made this
just doing a little bit of
experimentation
and it's all based on one photograph
so let's start by creating a new
compositions one composition new
duration three seconds 24 frames per
second 1920 by 1080 and we'll call this
into the darkness
okay so the first thing we're going to
do here is pull in an asset i have which
is under raster
and this is a stock image i found on
unsplash and i thought it was just
really cool i did a really simple search
for something like
creepy or something like that and i
found this image so what i'm going to do
is just hit alt or option
colon and it's going to create my rule
of thirds here which i have across the
screen and i'm just going to position
this
you know something like that doesn't
have to be perfect
and next i'm going to do is bring in
some footage we have here so
under my footage
here under stock
open this up i've got two pieces of
footage i've got ground fog and i've got
high angle fog and these are both two
pieces of footage that i got from action
vfx
that i thought was just really cool so
first i'm going to do is set this to a
screen mode like we have here and just
kind of position this maybe down here
and let's go ahead and bring in the high
angle fog here if you've seen any of my
videos before a lot of times what i do
here instead of setting this to a screen
mode i will actually use an effect where
i remove the uh the channel
so i go to channel and i'll go to shift
channels and just to show you very
quickly here if i don't want to set this
to screen because by setting this to
screen it actually adds
luminance to the image if i take this
back to normal here and i take the alpha
from luminance
what that does is it creates a better
looking key if you will on that fog and
at this point i can go to effect and i
can go to generate and i can go to fill
and i can fill this with a color
and do it this way but for the example
here i actually wanted to add some
luminance
to the image like so so we can get a
little bit more atmospheric fog so if i
preview this you're going to see what we
have here
let's actually go ahead and bring this
up
something like that and then right here
we're going to right click columns
stretch
and select both pieces of footage and
we're just going to slow these down so
that they're maybe around
24
so it just creates a slower moving fog
across the scene which creates more of
an eerie atmosphere which is exactly
what i'm going for here next i'm going
to do is we're going to select our type
tool
click up here and just type
into
the
darkness
and i'm using a typeface here that i
found uh on
a site i think i did a google search
it's called disordered
regular i'm gonna set it to 65 that's
just great go to my move tool here and
again alt option
colon and just bring this up in here
using the rule of thirds positioning
this up in this area here and it's kind
of a dark blue so let's go to
select it all and let's make it black so
we have just a straight up black and
white image here now this is a very
black black here and if you look at like
the guy he's not that deep of a black so
that's something to be aware of in the
future when we're doing the final
coloring on this so let's go ahead and
duplicate this layer bring it below the
layer and to this
layer we're going to go to blur and
sharpen and we'll go to directional blur
and we're going to create kind of like a
scary looking effect here where we're
going to
make it kind of blur out in the
background there so i'm going to turn
this up to about 30. you can see what's
happening
right here and we're gonna go ahead and
set a keyframe there and go to the end
of our timeline here and let's make this
40 so it stretches a little bit more and
you can see that the the type kind of
angles over here to the right so let's
kind of match the directional blur to
that so around at 10 11
let's go 10
10 degrees not percent uh looks a little
bit better so now we've got this kind of
effect where
we can actually turn this down just a
little bit more so we'll start there
and you can see we have this kind of
stretchy effect that's just growing very
slowly here
and it just adds a little bit of visual
interest to this type next thing i'll do
let's add some flicker to this right
let's make it a little scarier
so let's go to layer new solid
and let's
pick a color right in this area here
looks good we'll call this
flicker
and we're going to set the opacity to
maybe 50
and let's add a wiggle expression here
we'll type in wiggle
parentheses
let's go 6 times per second a value of
50. and let's also set this to a
transfer mode of overlay and let's take
a look at how this is looking here
[Music]
now right off the top to me it's looking
like the flicker is a little bit too
much
i like the variance but it's happening
too often so let's take it from six
let's just cut that in half and let's
take it down to three
i can already tell this is looking
better it's just a little bit slower
flicker
yeah i'm liking that a lot looks really
good okay so let's add an adjustment
layer layer new adjustment layer and
we're going to call this blur
and we'll go up here to effect and we're
going to blur and sharpen and we're
going to use a fast box blur here
and we'll turn it up to something like
15
and we don't want it to blur the entire
image so we're going to take our pen
tool here
and just start drawing
basically it's a very simple
vignette
doesn't have to be perfect
and we'll hit m for mask and we'll
invert this and we'll hit f for feather
and we'll bring up the feathering here
and hit v for my pen tool
and i'm just going to bring this
kind of out on the edges like this i
just want it to be more subtle i don't
want it to be super in our face
with the blur
all right next thing we're going to do
is add another new adjustment layer so
layer new adjustment layer and we will
call this one effects
and the first effect we're going to
apply here is under noise and grain
we're going to actually add noise this
time
and we'll take this to about
12
and it's already looking better and
let's also go to effect color correction
and we're going to go down here to
lumetri color
and under creative
we're going to select
sl
iron looking good the weird thing now is
like our type here our type is really
black right and everything else is kind
of like this blue black so let's get the
type
looking a little bit better so we'll
select this
and let's go ahead and just kind of
bring this up
to a blue
somewhere in this area is going to work
just fine so we'll copy this hex code
here and take it into the color below
and paste
and you can see it's already sitting a
little bit nicer the type sitting a
little bit nicer in the overall image
okay next thing we're going to do is add
a
layer new solid we're going to call this
fractal
and i always like to make my fractal
layers
black so make it black click ok
and to the fractal layer you guessed it
we're going to go to noise and grain
fractal noise
and we are going to turn the complexity
up to
10
and we're going to go into transform and
we're going to scale this up to 800 make
it really big something like that
and then for evolution options we're
going to alter option click on random
seed and put an expression of random
parentheses and we'll do 100.
and you're going to see this creates
this kind of
interesting fractal noise that's moving
around
and you're probably asking why are we
doing this what's this going to do so
i'm going to show you we're going to go
ahead and lock this layer we're going to
turn it off go back to our effects layer
and for effect we're going to go to blur
and sharpen camera lens blur
and we're going to bring this above the
noise and lumetri color layers
and
for the
blur map we're going to select our
fractal noise but it's really important
at this point that we change source from
source to effects and mass so it
recognizes the fractal noise and we're
also going to turn the blur radius up to
15
and then if we preview this you're going
to see
there's this kind of blur effect that
happens around the image
and that's because this camera lens blur
is looking at the fractal noise around
the screen here and it's looking at the
black and white values and saying okay
whatever's white we're going to blur out
whatever's black we're going leave
unblurred so it gets this kind of
interesting looking blur that's kind of
happening around the screen it's very
frenzied
and uh creepy at the same time right so
look up like this text here you can see
it kind of happening around
okay next thing we're going to do is
lock our top layers here and take our
type image and fog layers make them 3d
and the reason we're going to do this is
because we're going to add a layer new
camera
50 millimeters is just fine no depth of
field click ok
take this to the top
p for position right click on position
separate dimensions
add a x position and a z position
and for the x position let's actually
bring this to the left a little bit here
so maybe something like this and let's
go to the end of our timeline
and let's go ahead and drag this to the
right
and let's push in
somewhere in there and you can see here
it's looking really cool right we've got
it's very subtle but but uh interesting
push in on the scene so we're pushing
him with the type we're pushing him with
the character
the man there let's go ahead and alter
option click on z position and let's
type in wiggle
parentheses and 24 times per second
i want the z position to move by a value
of 12 pixels so you can see there the
effect that we added by adding a wiggle
expression at the z position so what the
z the camera is moving in the entire
time on this guy
and the type but at the same time the z
wiggle position is creating a frenzied
back and forth movement one thing we can
try is with the fractal noise we can
actually create
more contrast so if i look at this
we can pump up the contrast
and let's say if we go up to 200 right
so we were at 100 like this if we go up
to 200
it's going to create a
different
look to the blur so you can already see
like this is more blurred out uh maybe
if i drop down the scale from 800 to 400
it's gonna make
the pieces smaller so like now we have
n2
t is in focus but this is out of focus
so let's just preview this
and take a look at what this is looking
like
so here's what this looks like and it
definitely has more of like a boil
effect to it maybe that's the right word
for it
maybe this works for what you're going
for it's a little bit too much
for my
purposes so maybe we'll go back to 100
contrast
and see what that's looking like i don't
know if it's the 100 contrast or if it's
the scale that's too much for me so
let's take a look at this
and so you can get a totally different
look here i'm actually going to go ahead
and go back to 800 just like we had
before so this is the look that works
for me
really dig this a lot and let's do one
more final thing here to make this even
more interesting and that is by adding a
layer new
light
and we're going to make it a spotlight
and we don't need to cache shadows
let's go ahead and click ok and what
we're going to do here is i'll hit p for
position if we back this out
if i adjust the point of interest here
we can see is i can create a transition
on and
off
the screen here right so let's go ahead
and position this light correctly
bring it way up here
[Music]
and i'm going to open up point of
interest i'm going to set a point of
interest
[Music]
[Music]
now i don't have to go to complete
blackness here
something like that
same at the beginning so i'm going to
drop this down
let's hit aa on the keyboard
[Music]
turn down the intensity
turn up the
angle
and go back up here and just kind of
refine this
maybe something like that
yeah let's preview this
and there you go so the 3d light
adds a really nice transition on and off
the screen so for a title card this
works really well so there you go my
friends there is
into the darkness a title card
from a photo
i hope that you really enjoyed this
lesson as much as i loved teaching it so
please let me know if you have any
questions in the comments below i'd love
to answer them for you hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
please subscribe to this channel it
helps other people find this channel as
well if you're looking to upgrade your
design skill set master the art of style
and execute like a pro i have a course
called stylecraft that you can check out
at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]
you